hello all here I have at Star Wars
Celebration yet different backgrounds
sorry about that isn't a hotel room it's
a different camera I look like I'm a
politician filming a video please vote
for me I'm Jeremy Jones I approve this
message but I wanted to talk about the
40th anniversary panel at Star Wars
Celebration because it was it was a very
celebratory thing that I rarely get
these days with Star Wars here I started
out I'm not going to hit everything I'm
going to forget things ability didn't
talk about this I'm sorry just my human
ADHD brain apologies in advance but
stars that Warwick Davis introduces
George Lucas and the crowd went nuts and
I clapped for George Lucas now I'm not
the biggest advocate of the prequels I
totally get it but it was like in this
moment everything prequels related and
original trilogy related force awakens
related there was no divide that you
usually see in the Star Wars universe
like everyone came together to celebrate
that which is Star Wars you know it was
it was a sandbox of safety and it was
just really cool to see you feel the
energy in the room so Lucas is talking
about his vision and how he got started
with it the rumor is true he genuinely
has a dog named Indiana but it was
really cool seeing him talking about how
it all came to be was even a little more
loose-lipped it's like he sold the right
ways on order I'm not even attached to
this what's going on and on about like
the studio is when you sign with them
they want to take your entire life and
so it was interesting that he brought
that up because I never I'd never heard
that side of it before and then Harrison
Ford came out harrisburg came out later
if it was Anthony Daniels came out which
is hysterical was the Peter Mayhew came
out Billy Dee Williams came out and Mark
Hamill came out and I mean they're all
talking there's one seat left and
Warwick Davis like alright well we have
one more scene like here comes Harrison
Ford Harrison Ford came out it was just
a really really positive experience
among Star Wars it was really cool I
just wanted to I wanted to kind of gush
about it and talk about it and they
address the fact that it's there are
adults alive today they grew up with
Star Wars and the prequels happen that's
when I hit 18 or so and then so kids
grew up on the
prequels but those adults didn't look
like you then might not want me to say
this but Star Wars was made for kids
like I don't know what to say you know
so it was it was it was an interesting
perspective seeing as how every
generation still has Star Wars it
literally is in the DNA of the many
Hayden Christensen comes out he looked
at him nervous and I totally get it
because he has the Internet he knows the
situation of Anakin Skywalker in the
brick walls but he came to everyone
again thunderous applause and it was it
was really cool seeing no matter what
this is what the event did was you look
at these two and the script of the
prequels and the execution that you
might have problems with was all shut
away and in the end you're looking at
the fact of its Anakin Skywalker and the
Emperor like that's who you're looking
at it was a very important thing it was
very important part of Star Wars it was
a thing that I just kind of found
absolution with you know so Hayden
Christensen said a few words he looked
you know like you look kind of nervous
it was his first time like his first
does it since the 2002 or something like
that so I totally get it
Ian McDermott was really funny he was
reference acting bars you could tell he
was like Al I'll say some things about
the way George Lucas directed missing
that and how I got the role of the
Emperor again it's just you literally
see story time with these people and it
was a like I said it was a you weren't
seeing the prequels you were seeing the
characters how you might have wanted to
see them is again very cool moment then
there was this tear jerking the tribute
to Carrie Fisher there were a couple of
tributes to Carrie Fisher but when they
had this video montage of Carrie Fisher
and I mean George Lucas is talking about
Carrie Fisher and you really see in the
video she was genuinely a funny human
being like she is the epitome if you
know who you are and you accept who you
are all your strengths and flaws you
were literally the happiest person alive
and she came across as someone like that
I did I just loved seeing that and you
realize how good of a human she was you
start welding up and caring I mean I got
a knot in my throat that
lasted 30 solid minutes and I I wanted
to cry I just wanted to like let it all
go like screw it but I missed out on a
lot of it and plus I'm you know in a
crowd so I didn't want to do it but it
was you here sniffles sniffles sniffles
not a dry eye in the house it's all
welling up and then Carrie Fisher's
daughter comes out and starts talking
about Carrie Fisher and at that point it
went from a celebration of the Star Wars
legacy to the celebration of the legacy
of a human being when you see a daughter
giving tribute to her mother's life who
is no longer with us it was a different
thing entirely at that point I was if I
just let it go like yeah go ahead cry I
would have I would have just straight-up
broken down and at that point I was like
okay this is it
I get to go I'm going to go into a
bathroom stall and ball for about a half
an hour but it wasn't over yet in this
curtain opens up and John Williams is
there and plays the Leia theme to lay a
Han theme and then plays Morse I'd never
been to a John Williams concert
apparently I have now and it was just
the whole thing was so super celebratory
and magical that he's didn't wanted to
talk about it I mean I really didn't
want to talk about anything else I've
seen Jay is a great merchant emerge hall
but my only gripe is that they probably
should have saved that to last because I
don't think I'm going to see anything
including the last Jedi panel or any
revelation the trailer is going to be
great but it is not going to hit me to
the core like this did it was it is a
very special experience and it really
put down because you see a lot of things
online I read the comments I read the
tweets I see the videos very like any of
these people - you've had Star Wars
they're not intellectuals these people
like the prequels they're stupid these
people like the force awakens and all of
it was literally put aside it didn't
exist for about an hour and a half and
it was so [ __ ] refreshing that I just
I hope you guys experienced that like in
your daily Star Wars gushing lives I
really do whether you're 10 whether
you're 3 or 83 I hope you just you get
to experience what I experienced today
it was really perspective
building indeed that's all I want to
talk about I just wanted to tell you
about the 40th anniversary but I didn't
take video because I wanted to be that
you Louie CK has a great bit of people
taking video their kids plays it's like
put it down the high-def in your
eyeballs this is amazing you know so I
wanted to just take it all in so there I
took a couple pictures but that's it
there's no video of it so I'm sorry you
don't have visual aid but I just really
loved it I hope somehow you guys get to
see the video so you can experience it
all and if you do have that if it's
online I'll put the link below if it's
not I hope you get it at some point but
hey man if you saw it if you wanted to
experience it if you do experience that
awesome comment below let me know how it
is if you're at Star Wars Celebration
let me know as well and as always if you
like what you've seen here you want to
see more click right here to see more I
feel like the camera is way too far away
I got a lane here we go
[Music]